[MUSIC PLAYING]
DORINA ARELLANO: Hi, I'm
Dorina from Talks at Google.
I'm very happy to welcome
Kate McKinnon and Mila Kunis
for "The Spy Who Dumped Me."
[APPLAUSE]
[CHATTER]
MILA KUNIS: Oh, no.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Welcome to Google.
KATE MCKINNON: You all came.
Thank you all.
MILA KUNIS: How are
you reaching the floor?
If I sit back, I
can't reach the floor.
DORINA ARELLANO: Are we
all going to sit like that?
MILA KUNIS: How do you sit?
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
KATE MCKINNON: Yeah.
MILA KUNIS: These chairs are--
there we go.
KATE MCKINNON: Wow.
You all left your desk.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
Oh, you're a lady.
OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
Oh.
MILA KUNIS: Oh.
Well, my voice travels.
It's fine.
DORINA ARELLANO: Thank you.
OK.
So, thanks for being here.
I can't see Kate, Mila.
MILA KUNIS: Well,
otherwise I look like this,
because I'm short.
KATE MCKINNON: Hi.
DORINA ARELLANO: I
know, and it's OK.
MILA KUNIS: Fine.
I'll be up here.
Go ahead.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
So we got to see the trailer.
But can you tell us a
little bit about the movie,
just so they know?
KATE MCKINNON: OK.
I can.
It's two regular
gal best friends
who become embroiled in
an international espionage
adventure, for which
they're not prepared.
MILA KUNIS: That's
a good one liner.
That's it.
KATE MCKINNON: Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's it.
KATE MCKINNON: Chaos ensues.
Hijinks ensues.
Friendship ensues.
MILA KUNIS: Hilarity ensues.
KATE MCKINNON: Shoes enshoe--
MILA KUNIS: Ensue.
KATE MCKINNON: Shoes enshoes?
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's true.
I saw it yesterday.
They're not lying.
OK, so, the movie
does a pretty good job
of showcasing female characters
that are allowed to be human,
which is awesome, because
you don't get to see that.
KATE MCKINNON: Wow.
DORINA ARELLANO: Right?
Isn't that great?
Because you don't get to
see that a lot in comedy.
So it's really nice.
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
KATE MCKINNON: Yes.
You are correct.
Yes.
DORINA ARELLANO: Thank you.
MILA KUNIS: You're welcome.
DORINA ARELLANO: So,
this is especially nice
to see in comedy.
Is that what drew
you guys to the part?
Is that kind of what
you were thinking
about throughout the
filming of this movie?
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
I mean, I-- no, it did.
I do one film a year because
I have kids and family.
And so it limits the amount of
work that I can do out of town.
I was working on
a different film.
This project came along.
I was like, I can't do it,
because it would take me out
for six months, and would
uproot my whole family.
They're like, yes, but
Kate McKinnon's in it,
and I was like, oh, [MUTED].
So I read the script.
And then-- that's--
yeah.
And what honestly drew me
to it was the relationship
between two best friends being
incredibly grounded, incredibly
genuine.
Kate talks about this a lot.
But in so many spy movies, the
two characters have a fight.
And that's the catalyst for
like-- they have a fight
and you're like, but will
they ever get back together
and solve the world's problems?
So we don't have that.
Like, women, or people in
real life, don't always fight.
And so having that
resolved doesn't always
resolve other issues.
So I really was
drawn to the fact
that our characters were simply
friends on a crazy journey
together.
KATE MCKINNON: Yeah.
MILA KUNIS: So I uprooted the
whole family for six months
for that.
So clearly, I, too, am crazy.
KATE MCKINNON: And I am
so flattered that you
did, sweetie pie, because I
had the best time with you.
Thank you.
MILA KUNIS: God.
[SNORTS]
[LAUGHTER]
KATE MCKINNON: You know.
MILA KUNIS: No, no, no.
Next question.
KATE MCKINNON: It's like--
no.
Like, you know, in a romantic
comedy, in the best ones,
you love to watch their
sparkling banter and rapport.
It's fun to watch two
people on screen who
like to talk to each
other, who get each other--
MILA KUNIS: Who have a rhythm.
KATE MCKINNON: What?
MILA KUNIS: Who have a rhythm?
KATE MCKINNON: Yes.
And so to watch a
friendship that has that,
and it's genuine, and, I
daresay, in real life as well--
[LAUGHTER]
--it's just a joy
to watch people
who take delight in each other.
And that's what really
drew me to this.
And it felt so real, and like
my relationship with my best
friend and what would happen
if we really got sucked
into an international espionage
adventure for which we were not
prepared.
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
Correct.
DORINA ARELLANO:
So that's what I
loved about the movie the most,
is seeing a real friendship,
especially between two women,
where they raise each other up
and they're not the
stereotypical, like, bad '80s
movie, where they're
like being mean girls.
Like, that was
really great to see.
So you guys actually didn't
know each other before the film,
right?
But became friends during it.
So can you describe each
other in three words?
MILA KUNIS: Smart.
Funny.
Inspirational.
Don't [MUTED] it up.
Be nice.
[LAUGHTER]
KATE MCKINNON: Can
I use the same ones?
I'm sorry.
Those are the ones
I would use for you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Aw.
KATE MCKINNON: And may I
add, sparkling, vivacious,
entrepreneurial spirit.
Yes.
DORINA ARELLANO: Nice.
KATE MCKINNON: Honestly,
your entrepreneurial spirit,
in addition to your creative
genius, is very inspiring.
DORINA ARELLANO: Wow.
MILA KUNIS: Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Lots
of love going on here.
That's great.
OK.
So, in the movie,
the characters try
to pick out the worst song out
of a jukebox, which I loved,
as a music fan.
So what would you pick?
I know.
So many.
MILA KUNIS: As the worst song?
I like bad songs.
DORINA ARELLANO: I know.
MILA KUNIS: I like pop music.
I don't know.
I do.
Guys, I'm not that hip.
Like, it's not like I go see
indie bands in Silver Lake.
No.
DORINA ARELLANO: But there's a
bad song that you like, though.
Like, what is it?
MILA KUNIS: I like all of them.
They're all bad.
DORINA ARELLANO:
All the bad songs.
MILA KUNIS: They're all bad.
None of them stand
the test of time.
It's not like-- you go first,
and I'll think of a bad song.
DORINA ARELLANO: I don't know.
Like Chumbawamba, or something.
MILA KUNIS: "Who
Let The Dogs Out"?
KATE MCKINNON: What?
Chumbawamba is timeless.
MILA KUNIS: Kate--
DORINA ARELLANO: I know, but
it is not a good song, though.
KATE MCKINNON: And
prescriptive for living.
You get knocked down,
and you do get up again.
You have to.
What other choice do you have?
He drinks a whiskey drink.
He drinks a vodka drink.
That's Chumbawamba, right?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: You're right.
It's very philosophical.
Thank you for bringing that up.
KATE MCKINNON: He
sings the songs that
remind him of the good times.
MILA KUNIS: And the songs that
remind him of the bad times.
I know.
KATE MCKINNON: No.
Of the best times is the lyric.
MILA KUNIS: Oh, best?
KATE MCKINNON: See?
It's about positivity.
MILA KUNIS: OK.
KATE MCKINNON: [SNORTS]
[LAUGHTER]
MILA KUNIS: Can you
think of a bad song?
KATE MCKINNON: I know one.
I know one song that
I think is a bad song.
MILA KUNIS: What is it?
KATE MCKINNON: I don't
know the name of it.
MILA KUNIS: How's it go?
KATE MCKINNON: I don't want to
knock the artist right here.
DORINA ARELLANO: Do
you know who sings it?
Oh.
That's not the-- they usually
don't write it, anyway,
so you're fine.
MILA KUNIS: How's it go?
KATE MCKINNON: OK.
No.
DORINA ARELLANO: No?
KATE MCKINNON: No.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
KATE MCKINNON:
But I've been only
ever heard one song that
I was like, oh, wow, this
is a bad song.
DORINA ARELLANO: I
like to Shazam that
on the radio in the car.
KATE MCKINNON: Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: Anyways.
So the great Gillian
Anderson is in this movie.
And it appears that Kate and
I have a mutual crush on her.
MILA KUNIS: Really?
DORINA ARELLANO:
Because she's awesome.
So, Kate, at one point
you dressed up as Scully
from "The X-Files,"
which is awesome.
KATE MCKINNON: Yes I did.
DORINA ARELLANO: And
you also made a video
asking Jillian to call you.
It's viral.
I'm not making this up.
KATE MCKINNON: Yes, I did.
Thanks to the magic
of the internet,
these things never disappear.
DORINA ARELLANO: Maybe we
can get Google to erase it.
[LAUGHTER]
KATE MCKINNON: Anybody?
Anybody want to
raise their hand?
Help me out.
No?
OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: So
what's the weirdest thing
a fan has done for you guys?
MILA KUNIS: There's
lots of worst stuff
of Kate on the internet
than that, guys.
You can just-- you know.
There's some good
performances that you
wouldn't let me see that are
online, of you in a play.
KATE MCKINNON: Right, right.
You know, again,
anyone in this room
who would like to choose
to just hack the code
or whatever, do a little
cleanup, talk to me afterwards.
I'd be forever grateful.
MILA KUNIS: What
was the question?
KATE MCKINNON: What
DORINA ARELLANO:
Apparently you're
here to delete stuff
from the internet.
MILA KUNIS: I have lots of-- if
somebody's deleting something
for Kate, listen.
I'm on that train.
I have lots of requests.
Weird things we've done--
what was it?
DORINA ARELLANO: So that
was kind of a cool--
I think it was cool--
weird thing you did
as a fan of Gillian's.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh, sure, sure.
DORINA ARELLANO: So what
has been a weird thing
a fan has done for you guys?
MILA KUNIS: Lived in my house.
DORINA ARELLANO: Shut up.
MILA KUNIS: Pretty weird.
DORINA ARELLANO: No way.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah, for real.
That sounds pretty weird.
KATE MCKINNON: What do you mean?
You can't just give
us a little blurb.
You've got to tell the story.
MILA KUNIS: Someone
came in uninvited
while I was out of town--
KATE MCKINNON: Wow
MILA KUNIS: --and decided to
reside in my used-to-be home.
KATE MCKINNON: Because this
person was a fan of yours?
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
KATE MCKINNON: OK.
So I'd say that's pretty weird.
KATE MCKINNON: It wasn't
just a random squatter.
MILA KUNIS: Not
like my cousin, no.
It wasn't.
No.
KATE MCKINNON: OK.
Yikes.
DORINA ARELLANO: Wow.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
It's good, right?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
It's really good.
It's dark and good.
MILA KUNIS: But
everything's fine, guys.
[FAKE LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
Good.
KATE MCKINNON:
[FAKE LAUGHTER] It's fine.
[LAUGHTER]
For me, you know--
gosh.
No.
People just do nice things.
I get a lot of self-generated
art about my cat, Nino,
because people seem to--
maybe they've heard somewhere
that I have a very close
relationship with my cat.
MILA KUNIS: You have a
very unhealthy relationship
with your cat.
KATE MCKINNON: Well,
you call it unhealthy.
I call it a marriage.
I don't know what
the problem is.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, I've gotten a
lot of art about Nino.
And I appreciate it.
I love it.
MILA KUNIS: Do they paint
your cat, or draw your cat?
KATE MCKINNON: They paint.
They knit.
They make t-shirts.
MILA KUNIS: Do they know
what your cat looks like?
KATE MCKINNON: Oh, yeah.
MILA KUNIS: Oh, really?
KATE MCKINNON: Google it.
[LAUGHTER]
I can't believe we're like,
in the headquarters of Google.
MILA KUNIS: You're not.
You're not.
That's in San Francisco.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh.
MILA KUNIS: But this is close.
You're close.
KATE MCKINNON: I
can't believe we're
at like an outpost of Google.
[LAUGHTER]
MILA KUNIS: Next question.
DORINA ARELLANO: You guys
are killing me already.
OK.
In a good way.
So both your characters have
hidden skills in the movie--
everything from trapeze
to video games, shooting.
Are these things you do at
all in your lives, and more
importantly, do you
have any hidden skills?
MILA KUNIS: I have
no hidden skills.
KATE MCKINNON: I have--
OK.
I can make fettuccine.
Is that a hidden skill?
I roll my own pasta,
when I have time.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That works.
What else?
KATE MCKINNON: I play the cello.
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh.
Me, too.
KATE MCKINNON: Not well.
You do?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh,
let's have a party.
DORINA ARELLANO: We should
have brought it and jammed.
Can your cat come?
KATE MCKINNON: Sure.
Oh, no.
He hates stringed instruments.
Gosh.
When I pick up that
cello or that guitar,
he runs to the other room.
MILA KUNIS: You play the guitar?
KATE MCKINNON: I do.
MILA KUNIS: So you're
musically inclined would
be a good-- well,
it's not very hidden.
I feel like people kind of
know you're musically inclined.
Can you do, like, a backbend?
KATE MCKINNON: Whew.
Uh, yeah.
Probably.
MILA KUNIS: That's
a good hidden--
KATE MCKINNON: I'm not going
to do it right now, but.
No, I can't do it.
I can't do a back bend.
Can you?
MILA KUNIS: No, maybe not.
KATE MCKINNON: It's a very
vulnerable position to be in.
MILA KUNIS: I'm going to
say no just so I'm not
put on the spot of
doing a back bend.
KATE MCKINNON: Great.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
So I got a couple more
questions for you guys then.
MILA KUNIS: What's
happening, Kate?
KATE MCKINNON: Nothing.
I'm just-- I'm ready.
I'm ready for this.
DORINA ARELLANO: You're ready?
I see you're ready.
KATE MCKINNON: Yes.
DORINA ARELLANO: I see.
OK.
So if you weren't acting,
what would you be doing?
KATE MCKINNON: Carpentry.
10,000% carpentry.
Specifically, perhaps,
cabinet making.
But maybe just
general carpentry,
or refinishing furniture.
Also quite interested in
plumbing and electrical.
She's on HGTV all day.
I love-- I mean, to see the
fruits, the physical fruits,
the wooden fruits, of one's
labor after the day, I feel,
would be very satisfying.
And having refinished a
few pieces of furniture--
[LAUGHTER]
--I feel like I got
the ball rolling.
So that's my alternate life that
I may turn to at some point.
We'll see.
DORINA ARELLANO:
What have you made?
KATE MCKINNON: I
just refinished,
you know, some cedar chests.
And you?
[LAUGHTER]
You speak as though I've not--
MILA KUNIS: No, I
was like, keep going.
KATE MCKINNON: Don't make me--
MILA KUNIS: I am aware of this.
What?
What would I be
doing if not this?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
MILA KUNIS: Cooking.
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh, yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: So
you're a good cook.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: Nice.
What do you like to make?
MILA KUNIS: Everything.
I'm a pretty good cook.
DORINA ARELLANO:
You bake everything?
MILA KUNIS: No.
Horrible baker.
No.
No, no, no.
Like, I burn toast.
I don't bake.
Cook.
Like, I cook really
well all the time.
I mean, I can bake, but just not
desserts, I guess I should say.
Not like a cookie baker.
KATE MCKINNON: I have
to say, I'm the same.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
You and I both cook a lot.
KATE MCKINNON: Love
to cook Love to cook.
Cannot bake.
MILA KUNIS: I can't
bake a cookie.
Like, I literally--
you know that you
can buy those pre-made
cookies, and they're like,
this is idiot-proof.
DORINA ARELLANO: I
can't do it either.
Same.
MILA KUNIS: I will burn it.
Yeah.
KATE MCKINNON: You
know why, Mila?
It's because you don't
play by the rules.
MILA KUNIS: I don't.
I also don't like recipes.
KATE MCKINNON: Me neither.
MILA KUNIS: Like, to
follow directions?
Ugh.
Who does that?
KATE MCKINNON: Make it up.
Feel it out.
MILA KUNIS: It's like ideas.
Like, go in this idea--
it's like recommendations.
Yeah, no.
Done with it.
DORINA ARELLANO: So, if you
were stuck on a desert island--
it's one of those questions.
MILA KUNIS: Water.
[LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: But somehow
could access only one genre
of movies, what would you pick?
MILA KUNIS: Romantic comedies.
KATE MCKINNON: Horror.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
MILA KUNIS: I hate horror.
I hate it.
DORINA ARELLANO: You don't
watch any scary movies?
MILA KUNIS: No.
Like, I genuinely get scared.
And then I can't sleep.
And then my husband's like, this
is the biggest mistake ever.
Why did I let you watch it?
I'm like a 12-year-old.
DORINA ARELLANO: What's
the last one you watched?
MILA KUNIS: I haven't.
"The Shining"?
I don't know.
DORINA ARELLANO: Wow.
OK.
MILA KUNIS: I really
do get scared.
Like, I get very emotional.
And then I worry.
If there's a child in
it, I'm like, well,
where is its mother?
Like, I get very
uncomfortable, very quickly.
DORINA ARELLANO: The child
usually eats its mother,
so there you go.
MILA KUNIS: If there's a child
in the preview, I promise you,
I'm not seeing that movie.
Like, I am not kidding you.
If they have like a child, and
the door opens, and it's like,
mrahh--
I'm like, no.
Not having it.
You love that [MUTED].
KATE MCKINNON: I find
it very relaxing.
DORINA ARELLANO: What's
your favorite scary movie?
KATE MCKINNON: Horror movie?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
KATE MCKINNON: The
one that really
laid me out on my parents'
floor for a week and a half
was the original "Omen"
with Gregory Peck.
DORINA ARELLANO: Very good.
KATE MCKINNON: When he
goes into that grave--
spoiler alert-- and
finds the dead jackal--
ooh, wow.
MILA KUNIS: That's
what you want to watch
by yourself on a desert island?
Well, you and I should
not be deserted together.
KATE MCKINNON: But did you hear
her original answer was water?
And that's because she has
an entrepreneurial spirit.
[LAUGHTER]
She knows what she
needs to survive.
And she also knows
that she can sell it
to the other people
on the island.
MILA KUNIS: I would just
barter it for better movies.
DORINA ARELLANO: So who
or what inspired you
to get into acting and comedy?
MILA KUNIS: Oh.
I don't know.
I was nine.
Kate-- I don't know.
Maybe Lucille Ball, actually.
You know what?
Maybe Lucille Ball.
Because the first
thing I saw when I came
to the States was Nick at Nite.
And I started watching
a lot of that.
So it was a lot of "I Love
Lucy," "Three's Company."
I'm trying to remember--
like, Mary Tyler Moore.
Like, a lot of old, like, 60s,
70s shows, and predating that.
And so I think I
would definitely
say I'm probably
inspired by Lucille Ball.
KATE MCKINNON: Wow.
Cool.
For me it was just "Saturday
Night Live--" really just that.
And Mel Brooks movies.
MILA KUNIS: I love
Mel Brooks movies.
KATE MCKINNON: I mean, in my
house it was all Mel Brooks,
all the time.
You had no choice.
DORINA ARELLANO: Favorite Mel
Brooks movies for both of you.
KATE MCKINNON: "Producers."
"Young Frankenstein."
MILA KUNIS: "Young
Frankenstein."
DORINA ARELLANO: Good choice.
KATE MCKINNON: Is
there a choice?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: Which one?
MILA KUNIS: "Producers"
was the best one.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
So, last question.
I think we have time
for one question.
And then we'll open up the
floor to audience questions.
And I'll throw this and be
super awkward about this.
MILA KUNIS: What's that?
DORINA ARELLANO:
It's our microphone
that we throw to the audience.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh, that's neat.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
Unless it hits
someone in the head.
KATE MCKINNON: Only
at Google would they
come up with a
throwable microphone.
So cool.
[LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: So what
would be your dream role
as an actress?
[LAUGHTER]
MILA KUNIS: I don't know.
KATE MCKINNON: Truly,
there are so many.
There are so many
badass women of history
that I would love to inhabit
persona-wise and also wig-wise.
I will say that my dream
role in musical theater
is Ms. Hannigan, for any of
you who prize musical theater.
MILA KUNIS: They've
got two of them here.
KATE MCKINNON: Yeah.
I know.
It's Google.
MILA KUNIS: But, yes.
I agree with you.
I don't know.
I have nothing.
I can make something
up, but I don't--
you know.
I don't know.
DORINA ARELLANO: What's
the first thing that
popped into your head?
Like a rock star or someone?
MILA KUNIS: No.
DORINA ARELLANO: No?
MILA KUNIS: A rock star?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
You wouldn't want
to play a rock star?
MILA KUNIS: Like who?
DORINA ARELLANO: Anyone.
MILA KUNIS: Like Gwen Stefani?
DORINA ARELLANO: Everyone from--
MILA KUNIS: Like,
what are you thinking?
DORINA ARELLANO: That's the
first rock star you thought of?
MILA KUNIS: Who do you
think that I would play?
Look at me.
What rock star--
DORINA ARELLANO: Anyone.
Anyone from Janis Joplin to--
MILA KUNIS: Janis Joplin?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
You could do it.
Don't you guys
think Mila could--
MILA KUNIS: I have
no musical skills.
No.
I should be fired.
DORINA ARELLANO: You
don't have to sing.
MILA KUNIS: Yes, you do.
If you're portraying
a rock star,
you should have,
like, at least rhythm.
DORINA ARELLANO: Can
you not sing at all?
MILA KUNIS: Well, I mean,
I like to think I can.
I've been told I can.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Can she sing, Kate?
MILA KUNIS: No.
Kate don't answer that one.
I'll answer it for us.
No.
I know you love me.
KATE MCKINNON: You can.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
I know.
You're sweet.
KATE MCKINNON: I was
just agreeing with you.
MILA KUNIS: You're a
very supportive friend.
You're very nice.
KATE MCKINNON: Why don't you
sing something now and let
us be the judge of that?
MILA KUNIS: No.
Guys.
Here's the thing.
Don't worry, guys.
I do a cartoon
called "Family Guy."
And for 15 years--
KATE MCKINNON: What?
MILA KUNIS: --I
have-- again, Google.
Wrong audience.
They're too nerdy.
They're like, what's that?
We don't solve algorithms
or [MUTED] like that.
But for 15 years,
I've been like,
I'm not singing on your show.
MacFarlane made me sing,
15 years ago, three lines,
and it took three hours.
And I was like, I'm not
doing this ever again.
Three months ago, they put
me in a recording booth
and I had to sing a whole
thing of "Oklahoma."
So in a year, you will hear
Meg-- and this is, by the way--
if ever you see this, should
you ever want to, remember,
that's me trying.
That's me trying to be good.
That's all you need to know.
I don't need to showcase it.
Everybody will see it.
It's in "Family Guy."
It's coming soon, me singing
"Oklahoma," the best I can.
Keep in mind.
DORINA ARELLANO: Well.
Look out for that, guys.
MILA KUNIS: I mean, guys.
It's brilliant.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
So, who wants to ask
the first question?
MILA KUNIS: Nobody.
DORINA ARELLANO: I'm going
to throw this at you so I
don't hit anyone in the head.
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
OK, sweet.
KATE MCKINNON: Yes.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Mila.
I've heard Topher and
Ashton and a few people talk
about how great "That '70s
Show" was, making that.
Would you make a movie
follow-up to that,
or get back into it in any way?
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
I mean, yeah, it was great.
I feel like I'm too old
to reprise a 16-year-old.
AUDIENCE: But then and now.
MILA KUNIS: But would we--
yeah.
Of course.
We love it.
Plus, I met my
husband on the show.
So yeah, I think
the show is great.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Another
question for Mila.
Do you still play games?
Do you find time for it?
MILA KUNIS: No.
I have kids.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
MILA KUNIS: I know.
I spent-- what is it?
I'd say 20 to 24, 25.
It took up a lot of my life.
And I would shoot movies,
and you go on breaks.
So you get, like, a five
minute break in between scenes.
And I was like, I gotta go!
And I'd be on some raid,
and they're like, well,
you need to go back to set.
And I was like, shut up!
Like, I think it literally--
it was just too much.
It was unhealthy.
It was just not healthy for me.
KATE MCKINNON: I
have a question.
Raid?
[LAUGHTER]
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
KATE MCKINNON: What game?
What are raids?
MILA KUNIS: You do raids.
You know what I'm
talking about, Ray Ray.
Like, if you do
first person shooter
games or any of those games,
you can kind of pop in and out.
But if you're
doing a group game,
if you're not going through
the story mode-- ha.
You see what you started?
Then you are responsible
for your group.
And I, a lot of times, was
either like a healer, or--
long story short.
OK.
What's the next question?
KATE MCKINNON: A healer?
[LAUGHTER]
You do have secret skills.
Whoa.
AUDIENCE: That's one
way to catch a mic.
KATE MCKINNON: Whoa.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
about your hidden talents
that you were talking about.
You were saying that you
might take up woodworking.
Have you ever happened
to talk to Ron
Swanson about canoemaking?
Has that ever been--
KATE MCKINNON: Yes.
Yes.
I did an episode of something,
and Nick Offerman was there.
And yeah.
We talked about furniture
making the whole time.
What an incredible life he has.
Married to the eminent
Megan Mullally.
Sitcom star.
Comedian extraordinaire.
And he makes gorgeous
pieces with live wood edges.
Come on.
MILA KUNIS: He does
like the big tables--
KATE MCKINNON: Huge.
Oh.
Beautiful pieces.
Yes.
He knows what's up.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I have two questions.
Simple and difficult ones.
So the difficult one--
do you use any Google products?
[LAUGHTER]
And the simple one is,
since you mentioned
you have some
entrepreneurial spirit,
can you suggest any
Google products?
[LAUGHTER]
New products that Google
should develop or something?
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
I can answer this.
I do have some friends
working on a Kitty Hawk--
the flying car from Google.
So I can recommend that.
[LAUGHTER]
If you'd like to buy it,
you can contact Dave Clark.
He's selling them.
Sebastian is the one who's
working on the product.
It's a fantastic product.
I may go out to Vegas to fly it.
But you asked, and
I shall answer.
KATE MCKINNON: I
just thought of one.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MILA KUNIS: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KATE MCKINNON: She
speaks Russian.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KATE MCKINNON: I have an idea.
I was just looking at these
plants and I was like,
what about Google Irrigation?
[LAUGHTER]
It waters your plants for you.
It's a self-watering,
self-timing waterer.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll take 10%.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: Any others?
Oh.
I'll go in the middle.
AUDIENCE: Similar to
the question about,
what would be your
dream role, do
you have a dream actor that
you want to work with that you
haven't worked with yet?
And this is for both of you.
MILA KUNIS: I love Matt Damon.
So yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
It's OK.
My husband knows.
I love Matt Damon, guys.
I do.
KATE MCKINNON: You know, one
of my comedy heroes of all time
is Catherine O'Hara.
And I have never met her.
So yeah.
MILA KUNIS: I drove
next to her once.
KATE MCKINNON: Shut up.
What did she say?
MILA KUNIS: Nothing.
But I got really excited.
And it was on Melrose
and La Cienega.
And I was making a left-hand
turn, and she was in an SUV
next to me.
And literally, I think
I went like this--
[GASPS] and I think she was
like, who the [MUTED] is
that crazy girl looking at me?
And I think I just didn't
do anything other than look
at her.
I love her.
That's my story.
That's all I got.
That's a minute of your
life you'll never get back.
KATE MCKINNON: I thought you
guys were in the same car.
MILA KUNIS: No.
No.
On the same street.
[LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: I saw her at a
Yogurt Land and I freaked out.
MILA KUNIS: Which Yogurt Land?
DORINA ARELLANO: The one
on Sawtelle and Olympic.
So maybe she hangs out there.
KATE MCKINNON: What
flavor was she having?
What were her
toppings of choice?
[LAUGHTER]
DORINA ARELLANO: I don't know.
MILA KUNIS: I know.
I agree with you on that.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So during filming, did
you have any funny moments
that you had between each other?
You spent a lot of time on set.
Any pranks or anything
fun you all did?
MILA KUNIS: Um.
Pranks.
No, because we're adults.
KATE MCKINNON: Ho, ho!
Hey!
MILA KUNIS: No.
Because in between
takes I was nursing.
So I would honestly-- to answer
seriously, I was with my baby.
KATE MCKINNON: Pump up the jam.
Pump it.
[LAUGHTER]
MILA KUNIS: And then Kate
would just chit chat with me.
And then I would go
into my little hole
and pump and feed the baby.
Like, it was so
not that exciting.
I saw lots of bathrooms
everywhere we were.
Everywhere I pumped was a
bathroom and a little sheet.
You know.
What did you do?
KATE MCKINNON: Banana
peels, all day, everyday.
Yeah.
I killed a few people.
No.
I'm kidding.
I don't like practical jokes.
MILA KUNIS: I don't either.
KATE MCKINNON: Or pranks.
MILA KUNIS: Oh, yes, I do.
That's not true.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh,
you like pranks?
MILA KUNIS: Not done to me.
KATE MCKINNON: Uh-huh.
Right, right.
MILA KUNIS: No, I like
it done to other people.
KATE MCKINNON: I'm a
hypochon-- a hoppo--
[LAUGHS] I'm a
"hoppochondriac," so I
don't feel that I would ever
do a prank, just in case
something horrible went wrong.
Like, if you drop bucket
of water on someone's head,
what's to say that
they're not looking up
and they drown in the water?
[LAUGHTER]
Then you've got a
lawsuit on your hands.
Pump up the jam.
Pump it up.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
We've got--
MILA KUNIS: That doesn't
answer your question at all.
I'm so sorry.
DORINA ARELLANO: So we
got one more question.
MILA KUNIS: It better
be really good.
Make it a good one.
KATE MCKINNON: Shit.
AUDIENCE: Too much pressure.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh, my goodness.
What's it going to be?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Since social media, it's
going on super fast nowadays,
and everything is there--
since you're a
celebrity, and you
said somebody was in your
house, how do you manage that?
Like, in your personal life?
I don't know.
Like, we share everything.
Like, oh, we're here with Mila,
and we're having a great time.
And then a lot of people can't--
I don't know.
How do you manage both?
MILA KUNIS: No problem.
I don't have social media.
Neither does Kate.
AUDIENCE: Oh, cool.
MILA KUNIS: So that is how
we manage social media--
by not having it, Google.
So that's that.
But to your point,
the biggest problem
that I have with people--
that's a horrible statement.
That's not what I meant to say.
Like, as far as people taking
photos and posting them,
is when I'm with
my kids, I do ask
them to post it after I leave,
only for security reasons.
I'm like, just don't
post that you're here
with me if my child's
in the background.
I just don't want that.
Post it an hour later--
to your point.
But I don't have-- we
don't have social media.
But we've heard
of this "Google,"
and we hear it's great.
[LAUGHTER]
And you guys have
a Google phone.
We hear that's lovely.
And other great Google things.
Yay, Eric Schmidt, right?
Larry Page, guys?
I know words.
KATE MCKINNON: Yes.
Yes.
I use the search
engine all the time.
MILA KUNIS: Sergei.
Google.
Things.
It's like a verb.
KATE MCKINNON: I'm
always Googling.
I'm Googling all day.
MILA KUNIS: This
nice little girl--
the girl, to describe-- the
woman standing back there
had a question.
Is that it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Favorite
musical guest who's
been on "SNL" since
you've been on the cast?
MILA KUNIS: Good question.
KATE MCKINNON: Oh, my goodness.
Wow.
MILA KUNIS: I've asked you this.
KATE MCKINNON: You know what?
You know what?
There was this week when--
I don't know if
you've heard of Adele.
She came.
AUDIENCE: I've
never heard of her.
KATE MCKINNON: It was
that week that she also
filmed her live concert
at Radio City Music Hall.
And we all got to go.
And that was-- it's the
biggest venue in the world.
Maybe that's not correct.
But it sure looks like the
biggest venue in the world.
MILA KUNIS: Do you know that I
performed at Radio City Music
Hall?
KATE MCKINNON: What did you do?
MILA KUNIS: Finish your
story, and then I'll tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
KATE MCKINNON: Anyway, she sang.
Her glorious voice filled
the hallowed halls,
and it was transcendent.
What was your story?
MILA KUNIS: Well, because you
were talking about Radio City
Music Hall.
And at one point,
"Family Guy," we
did live readings all around.
[ONE PERSON CLAPS]
That's right.
One person.
Yes.
KATE MCKINNON: Fun.
MILA KUNIS: And so we performed
all at different theaters.
And we sold out Radio City
Music Hall a couple of nights.
And I was like, you
know what, if I'm
going to stand on the
stage and perform,
I want to put on some
tap shoes, and then
say, I can perform at
Radio City Music Hall.
So I put on tap shoes, and
tapped my way down the stage
once, and went, look.
I performed at Radio
City Music Hall.
And that was my big story
that I can tell people now.
KATE MCKINNON: Do you still tap?
MILA KUNIS: No.
[LAUGHTER]
But I wanted to say that I
performed at Radio City Music
Hall.
DORINA ARELLANO:
So you can totally
be a rock star in a movie.
KATE MCKINNON: That's
entrepreneurial spirit.
MILA KUNIS: But not well.
Just a failed rock star,
who can't sing or tap.
KATE MCKINNON: [LAUGHING]
DORINA ARELLANO: But performed
at Radio City Music Hall.
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
DORINA ARELLANO: So that's all
the time we have, you guys.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
MILA KUNIS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DORINA ARELLANO:
Everyone, please go
watch "The Spy Who
Dumped Me" on August 3.
It's really funny.
Thank you everyone
for being here.